did you have did you ever have to that
point where you had to like work on your
signature or
did you have a good looking signature to
begin with when you signed things
um i just used i still use to this day
uh just a regular like
cursive signature i'm so jealous i
literally just do like four circles
i would love to have a cool looking
signature but i don't know how to do it
because i never
i think joey out of all of us has the
coolest looking signature
which is hilarious because i came up
with that show
signature my signature um do we have
like a thing
because like i came up with my signature
i think in like it was the first con i
ever went
it was basically the first time i ever
had to sign something like someone came
up to me was like
and you made it up man i love your work
can you can you sign something and i'm
like
who who the [ __ ] wants a signature from
me you made that up on the spot i made
that up on the spot and i was like you
know what
good enough this is because it's going
to be my signature for the rest of my
life
while joey's doing his thing jump
because i remember the first time
i got asked to do my signature i look
like a deer in
i look like a lost deer in headlights
look at that that's
that's that's my signature that looks
cool that looks like a proper artist
signature i could sell that on yahoo
yeah i literally i was like okay what is
like a distinct thing about
a signature lots of like unnecessarily
long lines lots of like over
to the point where it needs to be
illegible basically let me show you how
it's done
so show me your signature mine's mine's
mine i think it's in between
and i was like okay i can't just like
write the anime man
i can see that you probably came up with
that in in in this
screen that seems like this that looks
like seats
listen you think when picasso was in the
museum you had to put up with this [ __ ]
listen let me explain all right
you have the c the d and then i just do
whatever it's always like i do the c
and d and i give up sorry this is this
is like you know okay i'll do it
this is like when the kid brings back a
drawing as well yeah
this is like when the kid brings like a
drawing to their parents when they're
like three or something and their
parents have to act impressed
like oh you did this oh it looks so good
it's not even that it's just like
put it on the floor when i'm signing the
packages in japan they'll be like oh
full signature please and i'm like oh of
course of course then i just do that
they're like
look at me like what was that that
wasn't full signature that's mine it's
not as good as joey's but that's pretty
cool
that's pretty it's it's okay
it's okay it's okay i can't read that
and be like yeah that clearly says gear
i looked at this and i'm like who's dan
honestly i this this is cleaned up
a lot because i have a unique one every
time this is [ __ ] you can
why would i want this ever i thought i
thought
i thought one thing that
for a new signature right so you guys
can think of one for me
which kind of style do you like the most
one one hint i need
[Music]
put on put on the top hat and the
monocle you know i go for the doctor
i kind of like this yeah right let's see
yeah i kind of like like
see dan pointing at the
my signature by the way if we get down
i
approved by your staff uh not usually
but in this case
probably what is this bad it's like oh
god it's a shame
i gotta ask have you guys ever had a fan
ask you to redo a signature
oh yeah i have because i i've had that
before
and that's why because my signature
looks a lot better than they used to
because before it used to
look something like this and i i i
remember i put
i put this on like on like a guy's shirt
because he wanted me to sign a shirt and
he dead ass looks at that
and like he was like can you do that
again please i can't read that
i got a good one for you all right so i
was at a bar with a friend
in the middle of nowhere in japan and
for some reason he thought it'd be
entertaining to tell
the the person at the bar i was a
youtuber i normally don't want to do
that
i hate it when they do because it's just
it's just like you're not going to get
it if i show you and you you're not
you're only going to be impressed by the
numbers and not what it is
right so it's like don't don't do it so
he does it anyway so i'm like quite
drunk and they're like can you please
for some reason they brought out a
cheeky [ __ ] like 2 a.m and i'm already
i'm already pretty i'm pretty drunk
so they hand it to me and i'm i'm trying
my best to
do this yeah right so all i do in the
end is just this
i do this and they were like whoa and
i'm like looking at my friend i'm like i
can't believe they're taking that and
they put they hung it up on the wall
in front of me and i doubt it's still
there they must have taken that down so
well it's like the signature that we did
at army army right
like one of the biggest ones and at one
part of this store they have
this just this massive line of like
maybe like 50 squishies from like
artists and like figurines like
sculptors and stuff like that proper
mangaka's proper manga
stuff like that we did a video there and
they were like hey can you sign a
squishy for us because you filmed here
and i didn't take into account i didn't
actually think
they were gonna hang it up next to all
these things it's just worth
nothing yeah yeah right yeah yeah so we
were just like [ __ ] let's let's just
do it like they're probably gonna
they're probably just saying this to me
nice let's just do it
turns out i went back like a week later
it's up there
on the wall next to these incredible
looking squishies
and it just looks like absolute dog [ __ ]
like [ __ ] we should have uh macaroni art
next like the banks
yeah yeah it's pretty it's pretty
appalling i was like [ __ ] it was the
first time ever i was like [ __ ]
i wish they'd just take that down okay i
don't want this clown it's like it's
like that horse meme where you have like
a really professionally drawn horse
and then the last third is just like a
kid's drawing that would that that's
that that's our drawing in army army but
uh
every time someone goes there now they
take a picture and tag us and they
tweeted at us and we're like please
don't run
just the shame just gets more everything
like japanese artists have such amazing
um signatures and they're all good at
drawing
and so i've always felt like that's a
huge like
complex for me yeah why are why is
everyone so good at like
autographs yeah but a signature class
that's that's why i was genuinely
curious do you guys practice this [ __ ]
because i had to make mine up on the
spot and that's why mine looks
completely asked like just practiced or
like i'm still trying to figure that out
yeah yeah because i feel like when we
all
like first had to do signatures right
like it kind of came out of the blue
like you weren't expecting it i feel
like a signature shouldn't be a burden
and when i ask a japanese person to do a
signature it's like give me 15 minutes
and a red bull and i'll be done
yeah no no no no you can just do like
some swiggles i don't care slap it i
don't know what
just i feel bad when they're drawing
something really delicate i'm like
this is just gonna like be in like my
wall somewhere i think the highest
pressure for me is signing a shikishi
because a shikishi there's a lot of
white space in the shikishi
and there's only so many ways i can make
it look good so like it's
when i have to draw my signature big
it's like it's like enlarging
uh 100 by 100 pixel image you know it's
yeah it's it's like minecraft quality
that we're talking about it's like 360
youtube
and it just looks bad because we're so
used to doing like the corner of an
anime poster so that it doesn't go over
it right
yeah you know ever since i made a w um
in japan like
i've had to uh have you know shikishi
signatures often
and i wanted one advice from me is how
to fill it up is just draw a lot of
stars
yeah but that's the problem right is
that like we have three people who just
cannot draw to save their life yeah so
it's just like
same here do i like draw an anime
character but i don't want to get like
deviant quality like anime character
next to my signature so it's like
what do i so that's why like at least
with my signature my one saving grace
was just like the cat face
just been like i have to add something
to this to make it unique and
one thing i've always found with like
japanese artists or like just voice
actors or whoever is that
they always have like their mark of like
identity
i'm just like what's it for me i'll just
put a [ __ ] cat i think the reason
like
japanese artists and and um entertainers
like have sort of artwork with their
signatures this is because they have to
sign squishy
and they have to fill up the white space
yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah basically just put a cat face or
make up an emoji apparently yeah
or star or just lots of something lots
of stars this is a problem that
99 of viewers will have zero
relationship with
really relatable time yeah